[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
house go and rent my name is Fiona ba bo
ba
welcome to a let's play that I've been
looking forward to a long-ass time I
just don't know why I haven't played
this before let's go on normal well I
don't really know what's going on in
that's how my sleep that's not here it's
head hurt oh no the little girl is gone
so this game is pretty much what all of
these freakin horror mods that I play
not all of them obviously but so many
har mods and so many game developers
have been inspired of and I think you'll
see a lot of similarities of this game I
don't know Cheryl it's strange it's
quite too quiet
this place is like a ghost
it is its creepiest [ __ ] - Cheryl sorry
that's probably not how he says it
tonight I can go alright okay I can run
to con Ed's diner is [ __ ] creepy with
the graphics I know the graph is our
oldest [ __ ] but that just make the
creepier in my oh [ __ ] wait here foots
I'm not doing this by the way taking
over oh yes shall not you brought away
from me it's gonna be coldest [ __ ] no
Cheryl is that Cheryl I'm pretty sure
it's Cheryl the question is why is she
running away
maybe it's an illusion where are you
going
yeah that's right Cheryl yep hey wait
stop sorry but that's nothing how I
would wrap it with that girl you get
back in the car you little [ __ ] you
don't disrespect your data that's not
I'm a data okay let's follow her
an alleyway aah
little girls are just so [ __ ] creepy
all right this is follow her Jarro
I feel like I'm playing heavy rain die
son okay guys so [ __ ] long please can
we find anything here no whoa how's that
okay I got this what was that I hear
something of it they went up dog what
[ __ ] dog oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] they weren't
kidding
that dog is [ __ ] up he had nothing to
say about this no I would be kind of
creeped that so here comes the creepy
angles which is really a great way to
utilize the third person but it's so
shed yeah I don't like this oh hell no
a baguette don't even worry about it
breasts we're in this together all right
God why from 1999 to having harassing
horror games clearly been proven now oh
[ __ ] that's strange
it's getting dark a good thing and
better than nothing I guess
come on dude this is giving me goose
bumps don't worry it's nothing new what
is that sound all the [ __ ] angles
what is this what is a broken wheelchair
what is it doing here why is it spinning
spin the wheel pit I'm not spinning it
Wow does anything I could see you that
okay ah
what the [ __ ] what is this
oh okay and says I'm think I took a
wrong turn somewhere it's not my type of
hood oh [ __ ] it's blood everywhere so
much fun oh the [ __ ] angles are
killing me I don't like that job but if
this okay I want to go back soon what's
going on I don't [ __ ] know
all right sighs hey Chang I'm starting
to sweat [ __ ] that
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
but if they come from an broken shut up
touch me round get the [ __ ]
oh no senorita holy [ __ ] oh oh it's just
a dream that was all just a dream
what am I doing here why are we please
so we lost the girl and went to a police
station was I dreaming I get pretty sure
how do you feel
I felt pretty shitty Oh like I've been
run over by a truck I'm alright I guess
yep glad to hear it yeah I'm pretty glad
you better be from around here
totally night why don't you tell me what
happened
sound so creepy wait a second I'm just a
tourist yep Desa Terrace I came here for
a vacation I just got here well that's
good for you brah I don't know what
happened my
something weird I'd like to find out
myself me too I think no I don't what
about the girl isn't he gonna ask about
Cheryl have you seen a navigator all
just turned 7 last month short black
hair of course my daughter sorry the
only person I've seen in this town is
you really where is everybody
I tell you if I knew believe me oh [ __ ]
I didn't know we were that for I can
tell something bizarre is going on isn't
she that's all I know I would be asking
a lot of more [ __ ] questions what's
your name there we go Danica Harry uh
Harry Harry Mason expect that Cybil
Bennett some stable I'm a police officer
from Bram's the next town over
okay Kyle can I be a cop the phones are
all dead in the radio too
well I'm going to have to call in some
reinforcements all right you do that
girl hmm
[Music]
hold it what do you think you're going
why do you care
my daughter exactly gotta find her girl
no way I'll give me a gun then it's
dangerous out there take this in that
case I need to find her now yeah you're
my little girl
I can't just leave her out there by
herself by your Logan so [ __ ] [ __ ]
have you got a gun what give me yours
please no please
ah I hope you don't have to use it
Oh before you pull the trigger know who
you're shooting good point good point
and don't do it unless you have to
why would a police officer and don't go
blasting me by mistake give her gun okay
thank you
I'll take it yeah thanks thanks a lot
girl I know how to use this you do best
to stay nearby I'll be back with help as
quick as I can
sure sure I don't need help
I am [ __ ] Harry maybe I should
check for something before I leave
well what what about that mustard no no
I'm uh started
okay whatever guy hey maybe we can find
a map health drink I don't see why not
all right cool hey Paul sit
oh thank you and I'm Matt I Paul say I
pase what am i doing there's a
residential area in that take it yeah
and we're good
thank you very much or maybe there's a
savior I don't know usually they had
like a same thing some day someone may
experience these bizarre events
hopefully they will find my notes useful
yeah
I was a say how do I save them oh I
can't I can't say well let's it's gotta
go out it's a it's a [ __ ] emulator
well [ __ ] I have to save the progress
project pretty much oh wait we got more
stuff a knife hello
I'll take that yes gimme chop nice
seriously so this is where Japanese come
from all right what is this a tape
recorder a radio it's a broken is that
it
it's a broken broken radio what else do
you want from me all right here we go oh
[Applause]
what's that
I know huh radio what's going on with
that radio I don't know I decide that
out now
Hey
all [ __ ] all Jackie
no no no no no no don't touch me bro no
no no no no no no I had a okay
[ __ ] this thing get off the dog
this is not a time to read a map I'm so
lipid game you serious serious how much
I don't even the log of Harry aims at an
enemy at a high of accuracy it's the
search mute rotten from them you to be
in front of her aim fire
I got this separation what's that huh
radio yep what's going on with that
radio all right the dialogue is so
awkward in old games I don't know why
they [ __ ] thing it's like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
oh [ __ ] this is the dream what's
happening to this place I'm yep
that if why did the girl go anyway the
radio might be useful for something that
radio is cursed I Talia I'm not touching
that god damn it fine I'll take it I'll
[ __ ] take it
yeah alright we take it we took it to
Tackett we procure the smack at the back
but we're going out and an ax a piss out
I can favors you've enjoyed to sembly if
you want to see more of this series so I
can know I think it's gonna be pretty
epic let's play so I hope you boys are
pumped for this as well I'm gonna start
a new let's play tomorrow which is gonna
be to the moon ish - don't worry you'll
find a primo it gotta be more like
that's right
[Music]
get get digging give me back okay come
on
I don't like this I don't like this at
all okay
how creepy